un an après la révolution du cèdre
commencé le 17 octobre 2019 l'heure est
au bilan
malheureusement pour le liban au constat
est triste voire très amer avec de
funestes événements
ce mouvement populaire a permis à une
jeunesse pleine d'espoir de dénoncer la
corruption d'un système politique ainsi
que ces dérives sectaires
nous étions sur place dès le début de
cette vague de protestation inédite et
les manifestations n'avaient rien en
commun fait dj en plein air stands de
nourriture mais aussi groupes de parole
entre libanais venus des quatre coins du
pays pour parler économie société et
politique des liens avaient été tissés
et les barrières brisé de tripoli à la
bâtie et chiites sunnites druzes ou
encore maronite se retrouvaient pour
finalement constater qu'ils vivaient
tous les mêmes galères au quotidien et
qui n'était pas si différent l'ébauché
d'un nouveau liban se dessiner peu à peu
avec une génération qui voulaient se
réapproprier l'espace public dans un
pays où 40% de la population est au
chômage
les jeunes avaient l'occasion d'exprimer
leur frustration et surtout d'envisager
la naissance d'un système laïque et
égalitaire
je veux un débat où bat la souveraineté
du citoyen c'est la priorité j'aurais
d'un liban civile jardin liban où la
diversité c'est notre point fort pas
notre point faible
1 les dons qui n'est pas esclave aux
agendas politiques d'autres pays
cette révolution a entraîné la démission
de trois premiers ministres au total en
l'espace d'un an alors que le liban lui
continué sa descente aux enfers
petit à petit les libanais ont vite
compris que les dirigeants ne comptait
pas céder leur place et la révolution a
changé de visage
les manifestations qui était familiale
voire festifs sont devenus plus
violentes
l'armée libanaise a eu recours à un
usage excessif de la force
mutilant même de nombreux manifestants
le facteur malchance fait aussi de la
partie la pandémie de kobe 19 et le
confinement ont paralysé le mouvement
populaire et surtout l'effroyable drame
qui a eu lieu le 4 août 2020 alors que
le pays est au bord du gouffre
criblé de dettes sans perspectives
politiques et sociales une double
explosion au port de beyrouth vient ôter
le peu d'espoir qu'ils restaient à une
population épuisée et appauvrie plus de
200 personnes perdent la vie
6500 sont blessées et 300 mille paires
de leur maison une fois encore la
corruption de la classe politique est
pointé du doigt
que faisait plus de deux mille sept cent
cinquante tonnes de nitrate d'ammonium
dans un entrepôt en plein centre ville
pas de réponse de l'exécutif et aucun
sursaut de la classe politique n'aura
lieu malgré la gravité de la situation
aujourd'hui le liban qu'on appelait la
suisse du moyen orient est un pays en
chute libre et des milliers de libanais
quittent le pays plus de 50 % de la
population vit sous le seuil de pauvreté
un niveau de crise jamais atteint même
pendant la guerre civile qui a ravagé le
territoire entre 1975 et 1990 plusieurs
facteurs expliquent aussi pourquoi la
révolution n'a pas pris le tournant
attendu il ne faut pas sous-estimer la
solidité du système politico
communautaire ces partis ont la chance
d'être soutenue par une base
d'irréductibles l'absence de leaders
capables de faire l'unanimité est
également un facteur important puisque
aucune figure populaire n'a pu faire
trembler les dirigeants politiques
actuels ce qui les conforte dans leur
influence alors même si la révolution a
été noyé par ces péripéties malheureuse
la colère est toujours aussi forte
la flamme de la révolte est encore
présente et les libanais combien
l'exploiter pour apporter un second
souffle à la révolution du cèdre